welcome to this video playing link must
this is hungry ring Wow probably
mispronouncing this charity it's the
name the number one play of Belgium I
see the number one player probably more
close to it if not it's very close maybe
I'm some god I may be bloody mature
chill off is actually still higher rated
okay no no we have a we have a Zurich
variation of the name zone solid set up
form for black let's see how to place my
pieces and get us probably all right he
wanted to prevent Bishop g4 h 5 g 4 h 5
g six so h3 was a good news wondering
should i go see six if there's some way
to get the bishop out to f5 this would
really be nice i could maybe I can play
Queen e6 queen of five looks a bit
unnatural but if he prevents it with
Bishop d3 I get the Queen over to age 5
which is also not so bad the traders
sound probably okay for me he's got two
bishops but the structures are
completely symmetrical them so this is
not a big issue okay yeah with the g4 he
wants to win even more even Midas
plundering blundering upon maybe I
should actually put the bishop on b3 on
a form b3 is this a good square I also
need f6 I need to play f6 at some point
and probably always going for this so
this I didn't it didn't expect at all as
it we can some d4 so much I can't even
go all the way back here to see a it
that's probably the best decision I want
97 f 8 f 6 and so on now his bishop is
Sir is problematic you can go c 5 and
Bishop c4 but then it gets traded off
and Bishop to b6 next
really I guess so King to e7 and Ruby
aid I can play a four maybe yeah but
anyway my-my am choice is limited here
okay
and it is we don't really want to take
don't want to take on now on that form
would like to keep it down keep it
symmetrical
and
not very happy it wasn't a very welcome
trade really ok
IFIF is got 51 and king of seven f5 is
the problem and Bishop age five
well time warning Jack I don't have much
choice in check I can also play a five
i justed actually trapped he can take
and and I don't move them they move the
rock anymore ah ok black resigns yeah
I'm really wonder I'm yeah of course
it's not very active but I don't think I
should use this really it's just a
matter of some precision f4 is really
problematic maybe it is too passive
right so that's possible but let's say I
play g5 here I still got a phone why
should I need I mean we foil in my book
is just not a good move but maybe maybe
I'm wrong now he's got before so I don't
really get don't really get to a
position where I can use the form so we
will get in this c5 business maybe this
is wrong Bishop F 796 58 the thing
that's what I think is that if i get the
rooks traded with this completely
symmetrical structure the bishop
shouldn't be am so hugely important but
maybe it is some it is too am too
passive hmm but unsure maybe maybe this
was better is this this type of setup
our then is the look t 7 immediately
this is how we played out and now this F
Forza is the big problem yeah I probably
must play 97 am i as expected this but
it's difficult to really do something if
if he just plays this kind of slow
improving moves maybe still what I need
to do it's not totally clear how white
um makes any progress him now I can I
can just shuffle maybe not very
attractive but probably probably a
better defense than then what I did yeah
a pretty tough game for the first one I
didn't play any warm-up games maybe I
should have okay thanks for watching